hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 6 WTF
video we finally found out who lashes
it's a bit of a WTF even though it was
somewhat predicted they did a pretty
good job of seeding clues and it's a big
change in the comics so just careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet let's do the craziest stuff first
and then work our way down so starting
with number 5 Andrew is lash so I was in
the middle of making my flash video
Tuesday night when agents of shield was
airing and people started tweeting at me
about Andrew being latched I was
actually really surprised sometimes even
if the story is telling you one thing
the writers will take it in a different
direction so love or hate the change
from the comics like in the comics
andrew is not lash lash is a completely
different character on a completely
different type of mission what they're
doing seems very similar like lash in
the comics goes around killing a bunch
of new Inhumans TV show lash doing the
exact same thing but their motivation is
completely different so I will give the
writers a hat tip for staying true to
their own story I know that they always
like to do comic book stuff whenever
they can but the big twists always need
to be in service of the story not not so
much paying off comic books so they've
been teasing Roslyn as a frenemy that
Skye hates when she's really trusting of
Andrew so now she's gonna have to learn
to trust Rosalind who's probably gonna
end up helping them deal with their last
problem conflict inside the group is the
name of the game it's just like the word
twist during season one wolf in the
henhouse
they actually twisted that phrase in a
funny way for season 2 episode where
Mockingbird was secretly inside Hydra I
think it was like hen in the wolf house
or something like that
and one of the other big reasons that I
thought that Andrew might be lash was
just lack of evidence for other
characters being latched like it was too
obvious like they were trying to make
Rosalind seem like too much of an
antagonist when really she has so much
chemistry with Coulson that of course
they're going to be working together
Andrew has zero chemistry with Mei even
though they were supposed to have been
married so maybe they play those scenes
like that on purpose
they want you to feel uneasy about him
even though he's the psychiatrist he's
supposed to make everybody feel better
about themselves and like that Ward
twists like you learn to anticipate
things like that so you guys can let me
know that like I mean do you like Andrew
his lash I feel like it's a really
interesting twist first character now
he's interesting he wasn't really that
interesting before speaking which on the
number for Andrew is trying to go after
Lincoln
and not just Lincoln specifically just
to be clear he's trying to get rid of
all those new Inhumans my thought is is
that he feels like he is helping like
all these Inhumans are causing all this
trouble roselyn's group has their way of
dealing with it
lash has his way of dealing with it or I
should say Andrew you can still call him
lash and call him Andrew or lash either
way but he's still that guy that was
married to meso like there's this
internal conflict going on inside him
that I think that they're gonna flesh
out in future episodes I think they're
gonna pick that up next week I mean just
like look at this picture here now
obviously the person that plays lash is
a different actor that they put in the
makeup just because he grows so big but
I just love this notice me senpai
picture it's kind of like the Hulk
there's two different personas there's
the Hulk and then there's Bruce Banner
two different minds sharing the same
body that's actually something you guys
should get really hype about and then X
Thor movie because even if it didn't
come across during Avengers age of
Ultron Mark Ruffalo said that the Hulk
is just as afraid of Bruce Banner as
Bruce Banner is of the Hulk I'm not
expecting any kind of cerebral Hulk
anytime soon but we might get a tease of
smart Hulk and Thor Ragnarok if you
haven't read the comics
that's just banner as the Hulk with his
banner of mind his mind doesn't devolve
into like the primal Hulk mind he gets
to be a genius that's almost
indestructible and that's not what
lashes but it's very similar like what
is Andrews mind like when he is in lash
mode my guess is that it's a different
personality in that like the two
different personalities inside of him
are gonna be battling it out but on to
number 3 mockingbird is back in action
finally off the bench Mae has to like
slap her around a little bit obviously
she thought that Andrew was dead so
that's why she's on the warpath but this
is like getting Mockingbird closer and
closer to her spin-off TV series Bobby
is one of the most interesting
characters that they have in their stabl
Adrianne Palicki on top of that is one
of the best actresses they have on the
show but they have way too many cast
members on the show they need to kill
like half of their cast off just so they
can spend more time developing a few
characters rather than spending a little
bit of time developing a ton of
characters so here's what I proposed
before the mid-season finale let lash
kill like half of the people that are on
the show right now you guys let me know
in the comments though like do you feel
like there are too many characters for
them to do justice on agents of shield
right
now in the problem with Bobby is is that
adrianne palicki can lead her own show
she's like me and Daisy put together so
she's better than like both of those
characters so why do you need me and
Daisy if you have someone that's better
than both well the show is built on
Daisy she's an inhuman so naturally you
have to get rid of Bobby
so Bobby is gonna go on the spin-off on
the number two though Coulson and
Rosalind are now like the new most
compelling relationship on TV they're
like the best part of the show that does
not involve action and there is a little
bit of action like Coulson with this
laser finger the other week when they
went to her apartment which I do think
is her apartment like the whole idea is
that she's being truthful with Coulson
and Coulson isn't trusting her you've
got my favorite food he have a bunch of
my favorite stuff all over the place WTF
are you trying to win me over but the
idea is is that Rosalyn likes all those
things like they're too similar so they
used the set design and the narrative to
tell you that she is a good character
she is trying to help despite the fact
that her casing up Inhumans looks like
something from a horror movie as Coulson
says and finally on my number one WTF
moment powers Boothe is Gideon Malick
the Hydra person that everyone else is
afraid of so I'll just start by saying
if you have not watched Deadwood watch
Deadwood
he is awesome on that TV show now the
character he's playing isn't somebody
from the comics it's an original
creation of the show but think of him is
another head of Hydra cut off one to
take its place there's always going to
be more heads of Hydra right now Ward
thinks of himself as another head of
Hydra Baron Zemo is a big one that we're
going to see during Captain America's
Civil War and I would say that some of
this Hydra stuff will tie in with
Captain America Civil War I think it
will a little bit but if you remember
the crossover with Avengers age of
Ultron that was actually pretty
disappointing last year you could barely
call that a crossover but they did
promise the TV show would crossover with
the movies more even with Thor Ragnarok
and I know a lot of people believe that
this planet here is the sentient planet
ego I'll totally buy that for now we
don't have any evidence that says
otherwise
but ego the planet is just from the Thor
comics that that's how you could tie it
to Thor Ragnarok now the idea of a
sentient planet is pretty far out there
but if Marvel can do a talking tree then
it can totally do a sentient planet and
Joss Whedon's brother Jed Whedon is one
of the showrunners like Joss Whedon
isn't super involved with agents of
shield but the way Joss Whedon describes
his brother
just in the most affectionately weird
way he's like he's just so weird Jed is
so weird so what's like the weirdest
thing you could do on a TV show it would
be doing a sentient planet I really like
that idea let me know in the comments
though do you want to see lash kill off
like half of the cast and do you think
that this is the sentient planet ego
from the Thor comics what I'm hoping is
is that they resolve both of those
questions by the mid-season finale so
they can move on to more Captain America
Civil War type stuff in the second half
of the season everybody just start
pounding their desks we want secret
warriors we were promised an Inhumans
team seriously though I do think that we
will see an Inhumans team up before the
end of the season but maybe not before
the mid-season finale lots of cool stuff
coming agents of shield is getting a
little bit more interesting with the
season there they're a couple storylines
that I'm not a super big fan of but I
feel like it's getting better with each
episode and it's a lot better than last
season and way way better than season
one so what's happening tonight is I'm
seeing Specter I'm also planning on
posting a Supergirl video my Spectre
review probably won't post so Friday but
I'll do like a non-spoilery portion in
case you don't see it right away but
there's a really big thing is that
Blizzcon is this weekend even if you
don't play Warcraft anymore if they're
dropping the full trailer for the movie
on Friday so I'm totally gonna do video
for that too lots of crazy stuff
happening I'll just be like sitting at
my computer 24/7 watching the Blizzcon
feed why guys wait for that to post you
can click here for the arrow Constantine
video from last night and you can click
here to watch the Jessica Jones trailer
that's actually coming at the end of the
month and I'll totally be doing videos
for it so thank you so much for watching
everybody it looks like five I'll see
you guys tonight
you